hey guys how's it going so i'm currently
in indianapolis for the indy 500 which
i'm really excited about this weekend
but i'm also extremely excited because
we officially have launched the ijustine
book contests head over to my blog
ijustine.com and it has all of the
details and we're giving away a bunch of
fun stuff we're giving away macbook i'm
giving away a snapchat friend follows so
i'll add you guys on snapchat and snap
you back might not be quite as cool as
the macbook but i'm also going to be
giving away nintendo ds uh there's a
bunch of other stuff on the list some
signed postcards
um also i have like old cameras and a
lot of crazy stuff that i've used
throughout the years that i don't
actually use anymore so i wanted to
autograph that and kind of put some fun
stuff in a box so it's the ij tech
archive box i can't even tell you what's
going to be in it because i'm going to
go through my apartment and just sort of
like search through and give you guys
some cool stuff so head there check it
out the book is officially out on june
2nd and i'm going to be announcing all
of the book tour dates they may actually
already be announced so check the
description
all of the information will be at
igestinebook.com
i'm excited i'm extremely overwhelmed
because i just can't wait for you guys
to read it and
i don't know i'm even more excited about
the book tour because i'll get to see
you guys and jenna's excited she's
taking a little nap over there i'm
excited she's really excited hopefully
she'll actually be at a couple of the
tour dates so i know we are gonna be
pittsburgh on june 5th that one has been
officially confirmed i do have the full
list right here but i don't want to give
away all the details just yet because i
want it to be 100 confirmed and you guys
can check your schedules and come out
and hang out so pre-order the book also
tweet me if you guys have pre-ordered
send me your pre-order codes make sure
you guys save those because those will
be very important go check it out just
want to give you guys an update i love
you so much and maybe i'll see some of
you guys at the indy 500 this weekend if
not i'll see you on book tour if not
i'll see you at another future event
sometime down the line i love you guys
bye
you